the administration is sending mixed
signals about whether separating parents
and children is intended to deter
illegal immigration CBS News radio
correspondent Steven Portnoy asked
homeland security secretary
Kirsten Nielsen about that yesterday are
you intending for parents to be
separated from their children are you
intending to send a message I find that
offensive no because what why would I
ever create a policy that purposely does
that no but just last month White House
chief of staff John Kelly said family
separation could be a tough deterrent
Mireya Villarreal is at the us-mexico
border in El Paso talking with families
that want to enter this country Madeo
good morning well good morning despite
some of those mixed signals of the
policy of separating children from their
families it has not led to a decrease in
the number of illegal border crossings
but when we cross the border into Juarez
Mexico just passed this border fence
we got first-hand accounts from people
who are saying that this policy is
deterring them you don't have any more
family here and that doesn't mean look
up we met this Mexican grandmother
Monday on the outskirts of Ciudad Juarez
she said she wants to cross the border
to join her daughter's in the US but his
scared she'll be separated from her
granddaughter if she gets caught so
Corazon you're not scared and the
president changed his heart she's been
staying at a place in what is known as
Kissimmee granthi a safe haven for
immigrants trying to cross into the u.s.
or who have been deported so this was
really interesting when we walked into
custom you get on with this this
definitely stood out these are the
detention bracelets that are given to
people when they are in the United
States and illegally crossed in are
never being detained as they come
through this particular shelter they
leave this kind of as a momento and they
go back to their home countries I live
in Salt Lake City Utah Gerardo Soto has
been deported twice he's been to jail
before and says he's afraid of getting
caught again if I go now they're gonna
you know
and I want to fire in jail and have
another charge but not everyone is
deterred according to the US Customs and
Border Protection during the month of
May when the zero tolerance policy was
implemented there was a nearly 2%
increase in people who tried to
unsuccessfully cross the border into the
u.s. compared to April for this woman
from Honduras escaping cartel violence
is worth the risk she said if she can't
cross legally she will find another way
you're gonna try and cross illegally do
sabes que Dios whether that they need
they can they can detain you the number
of families trying to cross into the US
illegally is at four hundred percent
last month that's in comparison to the
same time in 2017 when we spoke with
immigration workers in waters they also
say that they are seeing an influx of
people trying to cross into the US
legally but that are also being turned
away Gayle all right Maria thank you
very much